the decision to go ahead with d-day
relied on one man and he wasn't a
general or a politician he was in fact
two met office meteorologist a weather
forecaster group Captain James Stagg had
the job of advising the American General
Dwight Eisenhower when the conditions
were good to go the very outcome of
World War two would depend on him
getting it right say this is one o'clock
on the fifth one o'clock in the morning
on the fifth this is when d-day should
this should have been deeded correct but
we responded because of that yes because
as as forecast by stag the area of low
pressure has made its way eastward sits
now to the north of Scotland we've got
this cold front running down the channel
that were strong winds there was rain
producing visibility completely
unsuitable conditions for the d-day
landing these are the very charts that
James stack used to make his judgment
there were a lot of strict guidelines as
to what the weather had to be doing in
order for a successful d-day landing now
these included that it need to be within
a few days of the full moon and also you
needed low tides at dawn to choppy and
the landing crafts wouldn't make it onto
the beaches to cloudy and the
paratroopers wouldn't hit their drop
zones those sent in first shortly after
midnight on June the 6th could only hope
for the best when we hit the coast like
the anti-aircraft started up and the
pilots have to take evasive action but
we were all stood up down ready to jump
because what you you get up when the red
light goes on but as he as he reset the
evasive action over this anti-aircraft
fire even with that kit bag on my leg
we were all touching the table with a
fuse and I'd you know feat words on the
ground just sitting there thinking well
it was going to be late to land in the
glider in that sort of terrain and
inside a gun battery which now got no
chance why how are they going to land us
in there at 16 minutes past midnight the
first allied airborne troops landed in
Normandy the glider pilots brought them
in with impeccable skill despite the low
cloud cover they had landed with
50 yards of their intended target
pegasus bridge it took only a short
amount of time to catch it from the
Germans and then another bridge fell
nearby the coded message was then sent
back to Fleet HQ the two words han and
Jan mission accomplished
but d-day was only a few hours old had
James staege lost his nerve and advised
against going in on the sixth the
chances are d-day would have been a
failure the weather two weeks later the
next window of opportunity was the worst
for 20 years this is illustrated in this
document here from stag to Eisenhower
and this shows how bad the weather would
have been if they'd waited for the next
appropriate time with the tides in
response to this Eisenhower replied to
stag thanks and thank the gods of war
that we went when we did